the Android development immersive is a
full-time course it's a class that takes
people with little or no experience
coding and aims to have them be full-on
Android Alvers Android is the wave of
the future creating the next generation
of Android developers is so critical to
our mission it's so critical to our
global community it's changing the world
and we need to be a big part of it
Android is one of the fastest growing
platforms in the world with an
incredible need for developers to serve
the demand that there is out there to
build applications on the Android
platform and so we're really excited to
sort of empower both the developer
community as well as students class
experience has been really great
we're all from different backgrounds but
we all have the same motivation for
doing this program you have an
instructor that will be there to help
you out with that or whatever you need
you'll have students they'll be around
you that you can feed off we're
constantly teaching each other
constantly learning from each other
we're building our lesson plans we
worked with Google to get an idea of
what they thought was necessary from
Android developer to be successful
partnering with Google is always a very
exciting thing they clearly see the
importance of supporting the developer
community through efforts like this
that's gonna be exciting to go to our
Google's office in New York so yeah
can't wait the goal of the program is to
build people who are really ready to get
professional work as Android developers
working at some of the top companies in
the country and we've had Google guest
speakers dial in and you can tell
they're doing the work they're thinking
about it my day is going amazing our
full-time courses are intense
exhilarating transformative probably at
times a little bit overwhelming but
ultimately just life-changing the
student progress has been amazing they
came from no experience of being able to
make Android apps are ready for the Play
Store and you know seeing the projects
I've been doing lately that really they
are ready to jump into the industry they
took you from zero to a hundred and you
know created a well-rounded Android
developer in all of us we believe that
mobile development is a skill set that
is deeply in demand today there are not
enough mobile developers in the world
and were pleased to be able to help
create more I was really impressed with
general assembly and how they'd thought
through the instructional process and
how it works for their students this is
not one of those where somebody goes
home and they never use it again these
are people that are really thinking
about it and passionate and building
apps and as someone who teaches that's
like our dream completing ADI we hope
and we know that this will happen that
our students will jealously enter into
jobs as Android developers making stuff
building apps they're proud of and
ultimately doing work they love